[Music]
the show is started out hilarious and
keeps getting funnier and funnier would
you agree though that it's getting
edgier and that maybe this season is
edgier than the previous season in some
respects I mean we did have an
unflinching horse intercourse inter
horse course senior you showed some
horses having sex making love and that's
right the acting love it was very tender
money yeah it was it was I was watching
TV totally unprepared for that and my
eyes the gel melted out of the socket
for a second it was pretty horrifying
yeah well the clip of like that that
actually is is green-screen so Stephen
Tobolowsky and I did not have to watch
horses make love for two hours this we
shot no but we there is an extended clip
and there's a lot more gross things that
happen but the weirdest thing and this
was someone on set telling me about this
because I go figure don't know all the
ins and outs in horse breeding in the
scene you were there witnessing a a stud
for a lot of money having sex with a
horse because people pay lots of money
because they want the the genes sweet
jeans they Levi's and he someone was
telling me that apparently in at that
like upper echelon horse breeding level
there's the mayor there's actually three
horses involved three involved there's
the mayor there's the stud where they
want the essence yeah from yes and then
there's like a warm up guy and this is
and it's not a guy he's a horse that
he's a guy dressed as oh yeah
that's the job it's Union buddy a guy
like all right gotta go talk to you
later honey
get back on the copy gotta get back on
the horse boots and and yeah but there's
this warm-up horse that goes it goes and
gets the mayor ready
like I like playing it music what is it
doing buy get not getting on it oh I say
yes yes okay I believe care thing yeah
having its way but they in order to have
a non-compete clause with the stallions
essence right which is that worth
millions of dollars yes they yank the
warm-up horse out of there and just send
him away
before he's done he can't even really
yep he just sort of gets the mare ready
and then it gets sent out to pasture and
sort of like well jeez what do I do now
I don't have hands so I can't do
anything yeah and I think that is such a
perfect metaphor for like the the Pied
Piper like in the show that are just
getting warmed up and then like yanked
out before they can complete how do you
say that story on national television
without saying oh you just did you did
it yeah yeah you told it very
beautifully I thought
you